okay so before anyone says anything I am
doing Movember
so I am taking part in the campaign to
raise awareness for prostate cancer but
is Movember hence I am attempting to
grow a moustache I think actually for
three days growth this is this is pretty
good come on
so if you want to find out more about
the campaign especially if you haven't
heard of it before then I will put a
link down the bottom of the screen and
in the description that you can click on
prostate cancer is kind of like men's
version of breast cancer in a sense it
is that are gender specific cancer and
breast cancer gets loads of publicity
and absolutely deserves to you but
prostate cancer doesn't get quite as
much and this is a way a sort of fun way
to try and raise awareness of it so yeah
if you're interested have a look at the
website and um you get to see my face
fungus just grow every week I probably
hopefully hope be a bit more impressive
next week I wasn't throwing myself
shaving the only new piece of food that
I took this week was me in the library
which I think kind of says something and
the fact that I just spent a lot of time
in the library this week and I was so
bored of filming myself in the library
last week that is can't be bothered to
film it to be honest
this week that we're trying to do these
studious student acts and the speech
just try and get a good solid number of
hours in the library every day and just
don't want to have a repeat of last time
when I just had that that blind rush
towards the deadline but Tungsten's
learn from my mistakes basically so at
the moment in atmospheric physics I am
looking at well right at this instant
I'm looking at cloud physics and so they
called Cola Theory Cola don't have the
answer so we're looking at the theory of
how clouds develop on a macroscopic
scale so what height clouds are forming
and what height they pop out but also
what causes cloud drops to condensate
what kind of size you can expect them to
work out to given pressure and
temperature conditions what size ice
crystals will form in a cloud all that
kind of thing and that's one part of my
course I do this term I've also done
firm with a nice atmosphere so looking
at temperature structure and radiation
in the atmosphere that basically you
know looking lab energy that's getting
out
engi in and and time that and with them
global warming and later on in the term
that starting next week we will be doing
fluid mechanics of the atmosphere I
think at the ocean as well basically
fluid mechanics on a rotating sphere any
planet not just the earth we do look at
other planets atmospheres although the
lecture today so not today the other day
said them the last lecture in the course
which is on other planets atmospheres
will be quite short because frankly we
don't know that much then in theoretical
physics we are looking at that we just
finished many particle quantum systems
and thus a design called the Fox space
that's fo CK which basically is an
extension of the basic quantum mechanics
that you do in second year you do a
large course on quantum mechanics a
second year and this is an extension of
that system where you can allow the
number of particles to change so for
example that might be the case where an
atom is a new excited state and drops to
a lower state and emits a photon before
there was an atom and no photon and
afterwards there is a timer and a photon
previously the framework which we were
working with couldn't have dealt with
that whereas the new framework which the
the Fox space is built on allows for
that kind of complex situation so that's
actually pretty cool and I'm finding it
easier than I did the first time around
so that's good
really the big news of this week though
is that the thrived now for those of you
that don't know there is a youtuber
called John Green who with his brother
Hank green run the channel called the
vlogbrothers and if you don't know who
they are I seriously recommend you look
at that channel because it's the most
beautiful community of people a
community called no fighters that kind
of gives you an idea of what it's like
anyway John Green is a novelist first
and foremost in a vogue second and there
was an opportunity to buy all of his
books all of his novels that is Looking
for Alaska and abundance of katherines
Paper Towns and The Fault in Our Stars
there was an opportunity to buy all of
them and needless to say I it not least
because
not least because they were signed or at
least two of them was I'm looking from
Alaska in The Fault in Our Stars was
signed I have already in two days read
Looking for Alaska and it's fantastic
it's a red book or I've read it once and
I'm actually very keen to read it again
but I've got another three books to get
through and I'm really quite excited
about in terms of day-to-day stuff I've
slipped into quite a nice routine I wash
I feel like I've actually developed
enough of a routine to talk about it in
videos routine now is 7:30 get up do my
meditation practice before I start
working so that changes we might be
depending on what we did in the class
then I will have lectures in the mall
you know I have anything from zero hours
to two hours of lectures of lectures in
the morning on Monday for instance I
have two hours of lectures on Tuesday I
have none and then Wednesday to Thursday
and Friday I have one on average that's
a lot less the wine used to be for
instance in first year I had three hours
of lectures Monday to Friday tonight -
probably so this is not much this is
literally heart of what we have last
year but I will try and start working at
9:00 regardless of where my lectures or
even before 9:00 so my theoretical
physics lectures are always at nine
o'clock so that were typically they'll
be the first bit of work that I do in
the day where is my atmospheric physics
lectures at 11:00 so I can do Charles on
the library and then go to the lecture
and if I'm working beforehand it would
be like going for lecture notes or
students and praveshika work or whatever
and then so I the were called actors
during the morning then that's about
half 12 typically take an hour off for
lunch then work solid in the afternoon
in the college library that finishes
about five and then it varies from day
to day what happens next Monday's I have
my rehearse with my band at 7:30 on
Tuesdays I have my meditation class
about five people college on Wednesday I
go to the gym with some friends Thursday
I have physics Society meetings at 8:15
Friday it's gin and then on Saturday I
try and do the same country tune so I'll
try and work 9:00 to 5:00 but
I don't have anything fun good evening
and Sunday I tried to take off so there
dear is that it's a large loud bass
level of work and there's a modular
design in the evening such that if I
need to do work for instance on Tuesday
I have meditation class at 5:30 that
lasts for an hour and a half whatever
but then I have the rest evening if I
want and if I have the opportunity to I
can just sit with friends knowing that
I've been a fool that is work equally if
I'd like to carry on my work more often
if I have to carry on with my work I can
I have the option do I will I will
okay this is a promise if I put it on
the internet I have to do now I will do
a day-in-the-life in next week's episode
did I just call it an episode that is
extremely pretentious hey next week's
vlog I will do a day in the life I have
to do it now
I don't these are proving useful and in
places maybe even entertaining if you
have any questions that you'd like me to
answer or anything you'd like me to film
I will do my best to acquiesce to your
requests so have a great week guys I
will see you next Sunday I think within
about 36 hours of meeting him we were in
a3 like no no we were we'll borrow I'm
trying to film a video